I want that man's workout regimen if
anyone could find that for me and send
it to me let you appreciate the legend
of tarzan so the legend of tarzan stars
alexander skarsgård as Tarzan and Margot
Robbie as Jane this movie picks up like
10 years after the events of Tarzan as
you and I know it Tarzan doesn't go by
Tarzan anymore he goes by his actual
name which I forget right now as I'm
talking about it but he's living large
man he's living the good life he's
married to Jane but in the Congo there's
slavery and crooked [ __ ] going on for
the sake of getting diamonds and now
Tarzan has to return to the Congo and to
fix stuff up that is the briefest of
summations right there I am leaving a
lot of [ __ ] out because ultimately if I
gave you the cliff notes to this one it
would take three minutes alone just to
give you the brief point is Tarzan Jane
going back to the Congo Christoph
Waltz's in it he's bad news so here we
go and this movie had enjoyable stuff
enemies really exciting the scenery
first of all is the Congo it's just one
place that is the greatest place to look
at but never visit because you'll
probably die it's the Congo just but the
point is the Congo is a really neat lush
place samuel l.jackson goes with him
from the trailer I thought samuel
l.jackson was just gonna come to him and
be like hey man you should go back and
then he goes back you never see Samuel
Jackson again no he's actually a
supporting character of his movie and he
offered some comic relief some work some
didn't there were some moments in this
movie where the drama is kind of amping
up he's like ooh hey drama tension is
samuel l.jackson will chime in with
something you're like you just broke it
you just couldn't have marinated for a
few more seconds before you said that
but Samuel Jackson does have a couple of
lines that were actually really good one
in particular I was dying laughing
speaking of rush a lot of things in this
movie or rush not a lot of things have
time to marinate before it just jumps
onto the next thing if nothing has time
to settle in for effect then nothing
well oh but Alexander Skarsgard was fine
as Tarzan I mean he's a good-looking
dude he's super ripped in fit his accent
was a little all over the place
sometimes I'm like are you British or
are you not you're doing both but I
thought he was fine but Margot Robbie
all right when she was cast as Harley
Quinn I was immediately excited and
every time I see her in another movie it
gives me more and more excited Margot
Robbie is just growing on me in
already loved margot Robin she was tough
snarky sarcastic
Oliver scenes were good scenes I mean
she was just she added more to the movie
than any one character in this movie at
it yes that's me saying Jane added more
to the Tarzan movie than Tarzan actually
did Christoph Waltz is completely
functional but Christoph Waltz is
ultimately Christoph Waltz villain he's
completely typecast as a villain as a
villain he's always that well-spoken
very calm menacing in that calm way
articulate villain who sometimes has a
unique weapon specific to him that's him
in this movie and it's him that you've
seen a few times before that said it's
great casting for the movie I'm just
saying it's just nothing groundbreaking
you were like oh yeah him again does he
know he's being filmed at this point the
movie has great visuals when Tarzan is
actually swinging through trees being
Tarzan that's entertaining that's what I
can say about the movie the movie has
spots of entertaining the best parts of
the movie are the flashback scenes which
fill you in on the story of Tarzan and
Jane that would be the first Tarzan
movie bummer is they're very few and far
between and from what you see of them
more than fill you in it lets you know
the movie you're actually missing
imagine you're eating dinner you're not
really in the mood for this dinner in
particular but you have a hankering man
you have a sweet tooth and once in a
while you get a glimpse of someone over
there eating a banana split you just
kills you so what this feels like I want
to see that Tarzan movie I want to see
the movie where Tarzan meets Jane yeah
we've seen it a few times before from
what I saw in this movie if they took on
that plot I feel like it would have been
more entertaining more interesting as it
stands this tribal leader you don't care
about how's it grudged with Tarzan for a
reason you don't really know until later
on in the movie until they kind of just
explain it to you and in the end it all
wraps up and is over you walk out going
I really want to see that first stars on
movie that they didn't make before they
made this movie and The Legend of Tarzan
while I had entertaining things in it by
and large overall the movie isn't as
entertaining or good as it just wants to
be now I'll say The Legend of Tarzan is
probably a better time if you're drunk
ya know it's a party alright guys The
Legend of Tarzan have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you